Trascrizione: Valeria Benacquista
Revisore: Riccardo Sasso
Voi siete dei sognatori?
Io lo sono, anzi lo sono sempre stata
fin da quando ero bambina. Sognavo di
ballare su un palcoscenico e ricevere
tanti applausi.
Ero serena perché a casa
quando uscivano tutti,
io spostavo le sedie del salotto
e iniziavo a provare i miei passi.
Le mettevo tutte in fila, e diventavano
il mio pubblico, mi applaudivano sempre.
Le mie gambe.
La mia assicurazione sul futuro.
Volevo vivere di danza e diventare
una ballerina professionista.
Volevo investire sulle mie gambe, ma
proprio le mie gambe sono state le prime
ad abbandonarmi.
Sì, si sono arrese ad un nemico
invisibile, proprio la parte del corpo
sulla quale avrei scommesso.
È stata la prima ad abbandonarmi.
A undici anni ho iniziato a zoppicare,
inciampavo nelle mie gambe
cadevo per terra.
Non so perché, ma stavo male.
La mia gamba sinistra era rigida, rigida
come un pezzo di legno, sempre.
Ho iniziato a girovagare con i miei
genitori da decine di medici, facendo
ricoveri lunghissimi ed
esami dolorosissimi.
Ad ogni medico dicevo sempre gli stessi
sintomi:
visione offuscata, visione doppia,
stanchezza, rigidità muscolare, tremolii,
formicolii, scosse alla schiena,
scosse alle gambe.
Io, continuavo a raccontare i miei sintomi
e loro, di contro,
continuavano a dirmi che
era solo stress.
La parola stress mi ha perseguitata per
quasi vent'anni, fino a quando, all'età
di 29 anni, finalmente la
diagnosi è arrivata.
E non era stress.
Il mio nemico aveva un nome e un cognome.
Sclerosi multipla.
Alla faccia dello stress.
Quando è arrivata la diagnosi io
mi sono sentita sollevata.
Non ci crederete, ma l'ho considerata
addirittura una bella notizia.
E sì , perché quando insegui
per vent’anni una diagnosi tutto
ti sembra difficile.
Quando racconti tu i sintomi, ma ti sembra
che nessuno ti creda, vorresti scomparire.
Io da quel momento potevo ricominciare
la mia vita alla luce del sole.
Potevo ricominciare a camminare in
mezzo alla gente, senza più paura,
senza più nascondermi
E soprattutto potevo dire i miei sintomi
e non vergognarmi di dire ciò
che stavo provando.
Potevo guardare in faccia il mio nemico
e combatterlo ad armi pari.
Eh sì.
Beh, dopo la diagnosi io ho ricominciato
a sognare.
Sì, mi sentivo serena.
Ho ricominciato a sognare, soprattutto
quel palcoscenico magico.
Volevo continuare a fare quel mestiere.
Purtroppo la danza non poteva più far
parte della mia vita, perché le mie gambe
non ce la facevano più.
Ma, mi sono impegnata e ho studiato
recitazione per diventare un’attrice.
Ho smesso le scarpe da ballerina per
indossare quelle dell'attrice.
Ho fatto un cambio di genere di scarpe.
D'altronde molti attori dicono che un
personaggio nasce a partire dalle scarpe.
Tu ti immagini cosa mai indossasse
Giulietta ai piedi e voilà
diventi Giulietta.
Ecco, anche io in qualche modo
sono rinata dalle scarpe.
La recitazione è diventata il motore
della mia gioia, la mia
ancora di salvezza.
È stato bellissimo ricominciare
a recitare, ma non è
stato facile essere accettata.
L’attrice disabile in Italia suona
ancora male.
Per tutti, l’attrice è quella tutta curve
e sguardo invitante.
L'attrice con il tacco dodici?
Sì!
(Risate)
Quella con la stampella 112, ni.
(Applausi)
E pensare che nella patria dei lustrini
e delle pagliette io rappresento
l'emancipazione e l'innovazione
del piccolo schermo.
Eppure, per molti colleghi, l’attrice
disabile non andava bene.
Non riuscivano a capire come mai io
fossi un'attrice e avessi anche
un problema di salute.
Mi ricordo che una volta ero ospite in un
talk show; accanto a me un uomo dotato di
grande cultura.
Un uomo approdato alla
televisione per la sua testa,
per la sua intelligenza.
Un tronista.
(Risate)
Ecco, quest'uomo mi guarda.
E nella pausa pubblicitaria
mi fa: cioè scusa,
ma fammi capire, cioè?
Ma quindi tu cioè sei un’attrice, cioè?
E sei anche malata?.
Sì, cioè.
Te invece vedo che la parte del pirla
viene proprio benissimo, eh?
Cioé.
(Applausi)
Non ti devi neanche impegnare.
Si vabbè, non gli ho detto proprio così,
però avrei voluto veramente dirglielo.
Perché è assurdo! Che male c’è a portare
avanti il connubio arte-malattia?
E poi tu puoi essere un serio
professionista e
avere un problema di salute.
Non è che per sapere recitare devi per
forza saper correre.
Ma anche le mie colleghe non digerivano
l’attrice disabile,
anzi mi vivevano come una minaccia.
Quando sono approdata alla televisione
tanti articoli sono usciti dedicati a me,
tante copertine dei giornali e loro
questa cosa non la mandavano giù.
Perché quella copertina ha lei e non me.
Sono più bella, più magra.
Io spiegavo a loro che tutte quelle
copertine erano dedicate all’attrice
disabile, non all'attrice.
Tutti quegli articoli sui giornali erano
per la sclerosi multipla, non
per il mio talento.
Io ne avrei veramente fatto a meno e mi
sarei portata a casa una salute perfetta.
Ho cercato di farglielo capire, ma loro
continuavano a vivermi come una minaccia.
Tant’è che un giorno una mia collega,
collega attrice mi ha detto: <
fammi capire, ma non è che tutti i ruoli
da disabile, li devono dare a te.
Sono capace anche io eh!
E poi scusa...
(Risata)
Dimmi, tu che sei dell’ambiente,
ma quelli come te,
fanno parte di un’agenzia apposta?>>.
(Risate)
Quindi lei pensa,
pensa...
che come esistono le paraolimpiadi,
esistono anche le para-agenzie
per i para-attori.
Una cosa assurda, assurda.
Io lo so, ci sto scherzando sopra, ma
tutti combattiamo la nostra battaglia.
Probabilmente anche loro combattono
la loro, però insomma ragazzi!
Io ho studiato per fare
l’attrice e sono diventata un’attrice.
Ho realizzato il mio sogno.
Dopo la diagnosi non ho ricominciato a
sognare solo nell’ambito lavorativo,
ho ricominciato a sognare anche
nella vita privata.
Mi sentivo pronta per una storia
importante, per l’amore con la A maiuscola
e l’amore con la  A maiuscola
è arrivato.
È arrivato con un po’ di ritardo,
ma è arrivato.
Roby è il mio tutto, l’altra
parte della mela.
Con lui ho subito pensato di invecchiare
serena, di costruire una famiglia.
Volevamo dei figli, 1 o
2 potevano bastare.
Ci abbiamo provato, ma sembrava che
un figlio non volesse arrivare.
L’orologio biologico correva all’impazzata
io non avevo più tanto tempo.
Così ce l'abbiamo messa tutta.
Ma un figlio non è arrivato.
Abbiamo subito pensato all'adozione.
Che bello dare amore a un
bambino più sfortunato.
Un altro sogno da realizzare.
Peccato che quel sogno molto presto
si è trasformato in un incubo.
A noi un figlio non l'avrebbero mai dato.
Perché io ho una patologia
neurodegenerativa.
Io non sono idonea a diventare mamma
perché cammino con una stampella e magari
un giorno avrò bisogno di
una sedia a rotelle.
Che poi non è detto.
Avere una patologia
neurodegenerativa non significa
degenerare per forza.
E poi, anche se fosse?
Anche se io finissi
su una sedia a rotelle,
quante mamme in sedia a rotelle conosco
che sono serene e crescono con
amore i propri figli!
E quanti figli di donne in sedia a rotelle
crescono sereni, per nulla
traumatizzati e risolti.
E allora perché io dovrei traumatizzare
un bambino?
Un bambino ha bisogno di una madre
amorevole, non di una madre perfetta.
Un bambino ha bisogno di genitori che lo
crescano con amore, con attenzione,
non dei genitori che sappiano
fare 100 metri.
Questa è una battaglia che
io voglio portare avanti.
E come se lo farò!
Probabilmente a me un figlio non lo
daranno più in adozione perché
sono troppo vecchia.
Ma io voglio lottare per tutte le donne
che desiderano diventare mamme.
Spero che almeno il loro
sogno si realizzi.
E comunque, come potete immaginare, la mia
vita è stata spesso in bianco e nero.
Io ho sempre cercato però di colorarla,
di colorarla con tutta me stessa e di
renderla positiva.
Anche la mia stampella, il
mio ausilio ortopedico.
Io l’ho trasformato molto presto
in un accessorio.
Glamour,
fashion, tutto colorato.
Guardate!
La mia stampella non è grigia, blu, nera.
È piena di colori,
piena di vita come me!
I bambini le chiamano le
stampelle di Barbie.
Un bambino un giorno mi ha soprannominato
Lella, la fatina della stampella.
Io mi sono innamorata di questa
definizione e ho deciso di creare
un fumetto di Lella, la fatina
della stampella.
E vorrei tanto imprimerlo su delle
stampelle pediatriche o addirittura
pubblicarlo in un libro.
Lella, la fatina della stampella, è una
fatina che ha una stampella magica
che trasforma la tristezza in allegria,
la paura in forza,
la vergogna in opportunità.
Io ho un altro grande sogno, quello di dar
vita a una linea di stampelle dedicate ai
bambini e gli adulti.
E la vita mi ha insegnato che molto spesso
i sogni si realizzano, soprattutto
se tu li vuoi con tutta te stessa.
Io ho realizzato molti miei sogni, ho
realizzato il sogno del principe azzurro
e il principe azzurro
nella mia vita è arrivato.
Ho realizzato il sogno di
diventare un’attrice.
Ho realizzato il sogno di lavorare con un
grande del cinema come Pupi Avati e
soprattutto ho realizzato un sogno
che pensavo irrealizzabile.
Calcare il palcoscenico del
Festival di Sanremo.
Ebbene sì, io fin da piccola
sognavo quel palco.
Volevo fare la valletta, avere un ruolo,
ma essere al Teatro Ariston di Sanremo.
E il sogno,
un anno fa si è realizzato.
Amadeus mi ha telefonato e
mi ha proposto di recitare
un pezzo del mio spettacolo proprio
su quel magico palco.
È stata un'emozione grandissima.
Io mi sono ritrovata a marzo 2021, davanti
a 11 milioni di telespettatori,
a raccontare la mia vita, a recitare
un pezzo del mio spettacolo.
Le gambe mi tremavano come non mai.
Davanti a me non c’era il pubblico
perché in platea non poteva esserci
per il Covid
ma io ho sentito tutto il calore
del pubblico a casa che
mi avvolgeva con amore.
Avevo un vestito bellissimo, rosso,
grande, sembravo una principessa.
Avevo dei tacchi vertiginosi
e faticavo a starci sopra.
Anche la mia stampella sembrava
alta in modo vertiginoso.
Io quella sera ho realizzato il sogno di
raccontare me stessa, di recitare un
pezzo del mio spettacolo, ma soprattutto
di gridare al mondo quello che stasera
voglio dire anche a voi.
Io non sono la mia malattia, io sono
Antonella e sono la protagonista della
mia vita.
Lei, la sclerosi multipla farà parte
di me per sempre, ma avrà
solo un ruolo marginale.
La comparsa, da comprimaria.
Non di più.
Lo scettro della mia vita rimane saldo
delle mie mani perché ricordatelo,
gli unici protagonisti della
nostra vita siamo noi.
(Applausi e urla)